je donne maintenant la parole à madame
marie jo zimmermann merci monsieur le
président messieurs le ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le 8 mars prochain nous célébrerons une
nouvelle fois la journée de la femme
c'est l'occasion de rappeler que depuis
des décennies un travail considérable a
été engagée pour faire évoluer le statut
de la femme notamment avec la parité en
politique
toutefois il est encore plus important
de faire progresser l'égalité dans la
vie au quotidien avec une réelle égalité
professionnelle et salariale en la
matière de l'oise importantes ont marqué
cette évolution tout d'abord la loi du 9
mai 2001 initiée par catherine génisson
a mis en place un outil indispensable il
s'agit du rapport de situation comparée
lequel permet de prendre en compte tous
les éléments relatifs à l'égalité
salariale lors des négociations
professionnelles
ensuite la loi du 27 janvier 2011 qui
avait été proposé par jean françois copé
et moi même a ciblé l'égalité dans
l'évolution des carrières et elle a
pleinement porté ses fruits puisque en
peu de temps la part des femmes dans les
conseils d'administration des grandes
sociétés a quasiment doublé
malheureusement il est nécessaire
d'engager un nouveau combat pour
l'égalité salariale car la loi rebsamen
doute 2015 relatives au dialogue social
a complètement marginalisé le rapport de
situation comparée
celui ci a été intégré dans la base des
données uniques ce qui le vidant de tout
son sens car il est noyé dans l'ensemble
des informations du dialogue social et
ne peut être pris en compte directement
c'est tout simplement un recul de
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes
ce que j'évoque c'est bien l'égalité
réelle monsieur le premier ministre oui
vous avez créé un ministère de l'égalité
réelle
il faudrait maintenant que les actes
soient en conformité avec les promesses
dans le projet de loi réformant le code
du travail dont la présentation a été
reporté pouvez-nous vous pouvez nous et
nous
dire que le rapport de situation
comparée des sosies place merci la
parlait qu'à madame la ministre du
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle de dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marie jo zimmermann
avec la loi du 17 août 2015 sur le
dialogue social et l'emploi le
législateur a souhaité comme vous l'avez
dit transférer l'ensemble des données
transmises au comité d'entreprise dans
la base de données unique
parmi celles ci il y a les données
contenues dans le rapport de situation
comparée entre les femmes et les hommes
pourquoi ce choix parce qu'il était
clair que l'existence de nombreux
rapports distincts ne permettait pas
d'avoir un dialogue social vivant et
solide au sein des entreprises avec la
base de données unique
le comité d'entreprise est désormais
beaucoup mieux outillés pour assurer
dans les meilleures conditions ses
attributions en termes d'information
consultation
vous souhaitez aujourd'hui revenir cette
évolution voulue par le législateur en
faisant du rapport de situation comparée
un document à part je veux ici vous
rassurer toutes les informations
contenues dans le rapport de situation
comparée
je dis bien toutes ont été transmises
dans la base de données unique
il n'y a donc aucune perte
d'informations pour le comité
d'entreprise
je tiens ici à le souligner parce que je
crois que c'est ici un point essentiel
devons nous améliorer la lisibilité nous
pouvons bien sûr y travailler laissons
le temps donc à cette disposition le
temps d'entrer pleinement en vigueur
parce que ça a été je le rappelle
promulguée le 17 août dernier et nous en
ferons une évaluation particulièrement
précises si vous le souhaitez y être
associés j'y suis particulièrement
volontaire sur ce point j'entends
l'ensemble de vos préoccupations et vous
pouvez compter bien sûr sur moi pour
faire continuer pour que le combat entre
l'égalité professionnelle femmes et
hommes avancent dans le monde du travail
mais également aussi en politique
merci madame la ministre la parole
l'état